[MUSIC PLAYING]
TAD HUNT: Hi, everybody.
I'm Tad Hunt, and
today we're going
to be talking about optimizing
file storage for your use case.
If you are hoping to learn
about something else,
like maybe block
or persistent disk,
you're in the wrong place.
So I'm the product manager
for File in Google Cloud.
I'm actually a file system geek.
Before Google, I built
a file system company.
And I've been working on
File for about 10 years now.
In my spare time,
I'm a rock climber.
Anyone else do any
extreme sports?
Nice, nice.
I can't see much-- most people.
All right.
This is up in Yosemite.
Pretty cool.
Our agenda today is
we're going to cover
kind of an intro about
the file storage options
in Google Cloud.
And then we're
going to deep dive
into three managed
services that we provide--
Google's Cloud Filestore,
Elastifile's Cloud File
Service, and NetApp's
Cloud Volumes.
So just to be clear, what
are we covering today?
What are we covering?
Object, block,
that's somebody else.
Hopefully, you've gone to some
of those interesting sessions
as well.
We're going to talk about file.
So where do I store my data?
In this taxonomy
of storage systems,
we generally break it
down into some structured,
which is databases, and
unstructured storage systems,
like file, block, and object.
This is the file bit.
The key takeaway
here is that GCP
has lots of storage options,
whether you have structured
or unstructured storage needs.
We basically have all the
things, which is good for you
and good for us.
All right, so let's
dive into some file
use cases really quickly here.
This is not the complete
set of use cases.
There's lots of ways
to slice and dice file.
We're going to talk about
them in these categories--
general purpose NAS, some high
performance computing stuff,
some hybrid cloud stuff, backup
and archive at NAS gateway,
scalable caching,
and CSP storage,
which we have a
new name for this--
Cloud Services Platform.
Anyone remember the
name from the keynote?
Anthos, all right.
Good, good.
Cool.
So we all know
that file workloads
are incredibly varied.
And our first party
offering, which
is Filestore here
on the top left,
it won't always be
the best choice.
And for that reason,
we're committed
to supporting a strong
partner ecosystem.
We have some of our partners
up here to present and talk
about their offerings.
Meeting customers like
you where you are often
means providing the same
tools that you're already
using on prem, or that have
the advanced feature set
that you might need.
Our partners
complement Filestore
with things like
scale-out performance,
rich and deep feature sets with
well-established histories,
support for hybrid cloud
and container storage,
the ability to stitch together
lots of distributed storage
sites, and many more.
This is possible
because we believe
that a strong third party
partner ecosystem actually
recruits the best expertise
across the industry
to solve your problems
that any one of us
isn't going to be able to
solve all by ourselves.
So together, the end result
is you get the best solution
for your problem.
We're not, obviously, going to
cover all of these use cases
today, or the myriad other
use cases that there might be,
but we are going to cover a
couple of really cool, exciting
examples I think.
So if you are crazy
excited about File
and you just can't
get enough, we've
got a lot more storage
sessions about File.
I'm not going to read these.
Feel free to take a picture
or look them up later.
We're going to cover
some of the workloads
and the sweet spots
for Filestore, NetApp,
and Elastifile.
But these are a small
fraction of file workloads.
Google is actually ready to
solve a lot more of your file
storage needs.
I think, in my
opinion, we're the best
cloud for that these days.
We've also got
talks specifically
covering rendering,
hybrid cloud, and HPC.
And so feel free to
jump in on those.
You'll have to pick between
rendering or hybrid,
so if you need to do
some hybrid rendering,
you've got to split
your time between those.
All right, let's
talk about Filestore,
and then we're going to dive
into Elastifile and NetApp
following.
So today, I'm actually
super excited to announce
Cloud Filestore's
general availability.
It launched, actually, today.
[APPLAUSE]
So there'll be a big blog post
going out tomorrow with this.
So the two main differences
between beta and GA
is we have increased
the performance, which
I'll show you in just a minute.
And we've added an SLA.
So now we have a three-9's SLA.
It's live in production now.
If you check out the website,
all the docs are updated.
You can see all of the info.
So anyone in the audience--
I can barely see you-- but
anyone in the audience using
Filestore today?
One, two, three--
there's a bunch of you.
All right.
So NFS and shared file
systems are like the arteries
of many enterprise workloads.
And in a big way,
enterprise is doubling down
on GCP and hybrid cloud, in
part because now it's mature
and it can actually run a lot
of these enterprise workloads,
the long tail of enterprise
workloads that you might have.
With Filestore now
generally available
and the rich set of partners
we'll talk about a bit later,
you can make the choice to
lift and shift your apps
rather than rewriting
to object or database.
And so this actually helps
ease your migration to cloud.
Feedback during beta has
been generally overwhelmingly
positive.
And we've actually got PayPal
up here to talk about some
of the observations they've
made during our beta program.
So we're going to talk
about detailed use cases.
Like at a high level,
let's say that Filestore
in the general
purpose workload, it's
unblocked small to mid-scale
compute clusters and enterprise
applications that need access
to shared file systems.
Let's see, all right.
So Jason, put your hand up.
Everybody give mad
props to Jason.
He's an engineer on
the Filestore team.
So him and the whole rest of the
team have made this possible.
I just get to talk about it.
All right, and if you have any
technical questions afterwards,
catch him before he runs away.
Cool.
So here's a couple of--
maybe a top five
Filestore use cases
that we're seeing
from our beta program.
What's Filestore good at?
Well, obviously, a lot
more than this, but some
of the key workloads we've
already turned Filestore for
are rendering,
application migrations,
the sort of long tail
of enterprise apps,
web content management,
media processing,
and dev and test environments.
I'm not going to dive into
any of these right now.
The really exciting
thing is PayPal
is going to do a really
deep dive into dev test.
I think you'll be
really excited,
and it's pretty interesting.
What's one key thing
that all of these
and probably all of your
file workloads rely on?
Well, probably performance.
So we're actually pleased
to announced with GA,
we've increased
performance sequential
read on premium instances
to 1.2 gigabytes per second.
And we've increased
random reading IOPS
from 30,000 to 60,000.
So these are actually pretty
significant performance
increases.
And if you've been
playing with the beta,
these actually rolled out
midway through our beta.
And so you actually
get to take advantage
of this with no change
in price or anything.
So this is actually
super exciting.
So we didn't just
make Filestore fast,
we actually made it
really easy to reason
about the performance you get.
If you're price
sensitive, pick standard.
In which case, your
performance varies a little bit
based on capacity.
If you are performance
sensitive, pick premium.
Your performance doesn't
vary no matter what scale,
and you're not paying per IOP.
You're just paying
dollars per gig per month.
And it's a fixed flat fee.
And in fact, you
preprovision your capacity.
And so you know
right up front, I'm
going to spend this
many dollars on storage.
And so it's actually pretty
cool in terms of your pricing
and predicting your
pricing, it's great.
Let's talk quickly
about features.
This is kind of an
eye chart, so I'm not
going to spend a
lot of time here.
But at a high level, you
can configure shares up
to about 64 terabytes.
Premium and standard have
different minimum sizes,
so that we can guarantee
the performance.
One of the really
exciting things
is because you have to
preprovision your size,
not only do you
know how much you're
going to pay at the
end of the month,
but you can actually
grow it online.
And we have Stackdriver
metrics and alerts,
which can automatically fire
and do things like webhooks
to automatically grow the size
should you want to do that.
So you can get a
page if you're going
to exceed the capacity you think
you should pay for as well.
We are at about 500 active
clients out of about 5,000
connected.
That's kind of a small render
farm or a small batch workload.
Or even maybe a
midsize batch workload.
We're a zonal service
with high availability,
with three-9's SLA.
And typical recovery
time when we
need to reboot for software
upgrade or we detect an issue
is typically under
120 seconds, which
is within the NFS timeout.
From a networking perspective,
everything is super secure.
We're RFC1918
private IP addresses.
And you can access it
cross-zone and cross-region,
but not from the
public internet.
Anyone ever put an NFS server
on the public internet?
I've done it.
Don't do it.
It's not a good idea.
So you can't even do
that if you wanted to
in Google Cloud, which is great.
And like all Google
products, we're super secure.
We think security
is really important.
And so we have encryption
at rest and in transit,
according to the
rest of the platform.
So there's some details
and some white papers
that we've released there.
Integrations-- we are integrated
with a lot of the main things
that you're going to use
in GCP, like particularly
Compute Engine, GCE, and
Kubernetes Engine, GKE.
On Compute Engine, I
especially want to call out,
we're integrated not
only with regular VMs,
but also preemptable VMs.
So this is really great for
your batch compute workloads.
And Kubernetes
Engine, in GKE, we're
integrated with the CSI driver.
And so you can actually
dynamically provision Filestore
instances.
Speaking about
dynamically provisioning,
there's two ways
to do that as well.
You can go to the--
I mean, you can go to the
console, which is the GUI.
You can do it via API, or
you can use our command line.
But you can also use it
through Deployment Manager,
which is our native
offering, and also Terraform.
I think the Terraform team tells
me something like 10% or 15%
of Filestore configurations
are done through Terraform,
in fact, which is pretty cool.
So we worked with the HashiCorp
to put our integration
in there.
Cool.
Now, we're a storage
product, and so backups--
we're more traditional,
rather than object storage,
which is cloud native.
So backups are a thing.
We're integrated with both
Actifio and Commvault,
which are two of the leading
third party backup vendors.
Anyone using any of these--
Actifio or Commvault already?
Yeah, these are pretty common.
Couple of people.
All right.
And just to kind of
wrap up this section,
Filestore is available in
almost all GCP regions.
There's probably
three or four regions
which we're not deployed
in yet due to some capacity
constraints for us.
But that will happen
later this year.
And it's in GA-- it's GA in
all of these regions right now.
All right, so that's the quick
run-through for Filestore.
We'll have time for
questions at the end
if you have any
specific questions,
or you can hit me up or any
of the other presenters.
Right now, I'm paid to tell
you Filestore is great,
so you probably shouldn't
believe me entirely.
I think you should,
but maybe not entirely.
So let's fix that.
Please join me in
welcoming Dinesh Madavin--
I probably said his name wrong.
I only have American phonemes--
the senior software engineer
at PayPal.
He's going to tell us all about
the PayPal development team's
journey from
completely on premise
into completely cloud-based
development and test.
[APPLAUSE]
DINESH MADAVIN: Thank you, Tad.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Dinesh Madavin.
I've been a senior
software engineer
at PayPal doing mostly developer
experience, like ACM, Jenkins,
and deploys.
So let's get into
what PayPal is.
So this is our PayPal
journey to cloud.
We began way back in
2014 with [INAUDIBLE]
to containerize everything.
And we tried a lot of stuff.
While much of it was useful and
made developers' life easier,
the developer experience
team increasingly
struggled with growing
the scale and complexity
of managing the systems.
This led us directly
to the decision
to migrate everything
to cloud, so that Google
could carry on the
burden of keeping
the infrastructure
healthy and we
could focus on developer
experience, rather than
the infrastructure.
To put this in some
context, in 2013,
we started the journey with
one monolithic Jenkins,
with hundreds of plugins,
and more than 40,000 jobs,
running on a DL980.
And this got better after
we migrated to OpenStack
and we used Mesos, Marathon,
and Docker from 2014 to 2016.
And by 2018, we were
creating so many jobs
that we were not able to scale.
So we had to--
it was a pain to set up our
own infrastructure, which
was a bottleneck
for our developers.
So we started migrating
to Google Cloud.
In 2018, we started migrating
all our dev and test
to cloud, which has enabled
us to scale to more than 12
million jobs per year.
We are truly scalable now.
And this was a huge win for us.
And in 2019, we are planning to
migrate our mobile SDLC also,
and use Filestore for
more use cases at PayPal.
So to understand why
Filestore is important to us,
I need to describe our
development architecture
and scale.
We'll start with
that, and then dive
into where Filestore
helps us out.
We were early
adopters of Filestore.
We were amongst the
very first customer
when it launched in beta
back in July of 2018, which
means that we can also cover
our experience with Filestore's
reliability and availability
during that time.
Finally, I'll wrap up
by talking about what we
are going to do next and
what kind of platform
we're giving to our developers.
So this is our architecture.
PayPal's developer
experience is centralized
around a continuous integration
and continuous deployment
pipeline built on
top of Jenkins,
the leading open
source automation
server, Mesos, Aurora,
Zookeeper, MongoDB, and NGINX.
When developer
commits their code,
a build is automatically
kicked off.
Our unit tests are run.
And the Docker image that is
built is deployed to a server.
And all the functional
tests are completed,
and it's automatically approved
to be pushed to production.
And this basically happens,
everything in a Jenkins core,
Jenkins master.
That is the core of our
development architecture.
So we make sure each
development team is not
blocked by any other team by
providing one Jenkins master
for every team that's there.
We also use Mesos to orchestrate
our Jenkins master and slaves,
which enables us to
manage our fleet of GC VMs
as a single pool of
resources that we can
scale up and down on demand.
Of all this, we also provide
a continuous integration API
which encapsulates our
CI/CD functionality.
Our Aurora framework
schedules around running
process and our Cron jobs.
Filestore here provides
persistent storage
for our Jenkins masters.
We are able to scale the
number of Filestore instances
sublinearly with respect to
the number of Jenkins masters,
which is not just a testament
to the Filestore's performance,
but also helps
with manageability
because there are less
resources to keep track of.
So before Filestore,
each Jenkins master
also included the CI data.
This means that the
backup has to back up
all the CI data that was inside
the Jenkins master container.
You can recall that we
were well on our way
to 5,000 Jenkins
master containers.
And as you can imagine, this
was a huge scalability issue
for us, and also, it was not as
reliable as we want it to be.
And all the data that was in the
CI we were backing up to GCS,
and learned that encryption,
compression, and network
latency is not your friend.
So during this era
of rapid growth,
we were in never-ending
cycle of container failures
and also data loss, and
leading to a poor, unproductive
developer experience.
So we stepped back and looked
for alternative solutions.
Naturally, we thought that
making the container stateless
is the way to go.
And Filestore was launching
beta at the same time.
And it turned out that
this was exactly what we
needed to [? refactor ?] the
statefulness of [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's talk about our
use case with Filestore.
So what we did was
we were backing up
everything in our containers.
And the containers was
going out of memory.
So we completely
removed the process
of backing up and restoring
from inside the container,
and we moved all our
data to the Filestore.
And we were able to scale our
containers to more than 5,000.
And we were putting it on
Filestore instances mounted
on multiple VMs.
And because we moved our
architecture to the Filestore,
we were able to completely get
rid of the container backups.
And after moving
to the new process,
we were able to start up
our containers from-- which
was taking many hours,
sometimes three to four hours,
to less than a minute,
which was a huge win for us.
So you can recall from
my earlier comments
that we have been Filestore
customers since beta launch.
And we have seen the
service go from where
we weren't sure we could run
in production to a point where
we are pleased with this
reliability and availability.
When we migrated to Filestore
last year, we were [INAUDIBLE]
matrix tracked multiple
outages, which sometimes
lasted more than 10 minutes.
And this caused our workloads
to freeze and developments
to stall.
This means that all
of PayPal could not
run any builds or any deploys,
and everything was frozen.
We worked closely with the
Filestore team on these issues.
And over the last six
months, we have not
seen one issue where
Filestore exceeded the SLA.
And this was not even
officially GA yet.
So it is a good thing.
This significantly
reduced our support
costs, which is a fancy
way of putting that I'm not
getting paged anymore.
[LAUGHS] So the most important
outcome of this thing
is our developers are no longer
experiencing productivity loss
due to the CI/CD
system being down.
So moving forward, we are
looking at more performance
intensive workloads and
to run our builds also
on the Filestore.
Currently, we are using
a local SSD exported.
We don't expect network
attached storage
to be quite as
fast as the local,
but we think that
it's fast enough
and the performance trade-off
is worth this simplification
to build this slave environment.
We have just begun looking
into the restructuring
of our Android and iOS
mobile build and test,
and we think that we'll
also get the similar level
of maintainability and
scalability our of Filestore.
Thanks for listening, everyone.
That's what's up at PayPal.
And I'll call Tad
back and hand it off.
[APPLAUSE]
TAD HUNT: Thanks, Dinesh.
Cool, that was great.
It's not every day that a
development organization
the size of PayPal's makes
such a large sweeping change
in a migration like this.
So it's pretty exciting to
have them part of the Filestore
beta, and to help make
Filestore the strong product
that it is now in terms
of its SLA and features.
If you have questions
about this or anything else
as we go along, Dinesh
and everyone else
will be available
for Q&A at the end.
And he'll be around the
conference, I think,
a little bit more as well.
So if you run into
him, definitely
get the inside scoop.
Next up, we're going to talk
about Elastifile's recently
launched cloud file service.
So I'd like to introduce
Allon Cohen and Devin
Lehman from Elastifile
and Google respectively.
Come on up.
DEVIN LEHMAN:
Awesome, thanks Tad.
So bridging off Tad's
rock climbing photo,
I wanted to show that
I'm a snowboarder who's--
oops, sorry-- lucky
enough to work at Google.
But I didn't have any
snowboarding photos handy,
so that's a photo
of me jumping out
of a perfectly good airplane.
And for my day job, I'm an
engineering program manager
on GCP who's responsible for
working with our technology
partners, like Elastifile.
And so I'm up here with
my colleague, Allon Cohen.
ALLON COHEN: Thank you, Devin.
So this is a before picture.
The after picture
isn't this pretty.
We'll be introducing to you
the Elastifile file service.
And--
DEVIN LEHMAN: Sorry.
I stole your clicker.
ALLON COHEN: Thank you.
So Elastifile offers a
fully managed file storage
as a service inside
Google Cloud.
We're POSIX
compliant, which means
that you can move enterprise
workloads, such as SAP,
directly to the cloud without
the need for refactoring.
We are scalable, and this is
one of our key differentiators.
And we'll show you this
shortly in the demo as well.
Because we are software
defined, essentially you
can dynamically grow us
and shrink us upon need.
And you are charged
by the minute.
When you use more, you
pay as much as you use.
When you don't need
it anymore, you
can just shrink it down
or close it up altogether.
We provide enterprise feature
sets, such as HA, snapshots,
dedup, compression.
So we really can
migrate and move
to working the way you
worked on prem, even
as you migrate into the cloud.
And we are cloud native.
As a software
offering, we appear
in any region in any
zone, and can even
offer the service across zones.
Anywhere where Google
provides infrastructure,
we can provide our file service.
We are fully integrated
into the Google environment,
including both on
prem and the new--
or including both cloud and
the new on prem offerings.
And you can get our billing
through Google billing
and access us through Google UI.
You don't need to believe
me, because I'll give it back
to Devin and we will
demonstrate it for you.
DEVIN LEHMAN:
Great, thanks Allon.
So if we could switch over to
my laptop, that'd be great.
This will be kind of awkward.
I have to like type in
and use the hand link.
But what we're going
to show you today
is, bridging off what
Allon said, how easy it
is to find, enable, and then
create an Elastifile cluster
all from the GCP console.
So if you've ever
used GCP before,
you're going to see it's the
exact same look and feel,
from deploying anything
like Cloud Storage.
I get a tile.
Clearly says Elastifile.
There's syntax
branding Elastifile.
But it's all powered by
Elastifile's backend.
I hit Manage, it brings
me into the product page,
in which you're going
to see cluster details.
So no need to run scripts.
No need for authorization
or authentication protocols.
I just hit Create.
And within the product page,
I get the standard syntax
you'd expect.
So file name-- we can
call it test-next.
Region deployment-- and
this is super important.
I want to talk about
this for a second.
So Elastifile's
Managed File Service
is deployed holistically on GCP.
So similar to Filestore,
any region where
we have PD and compute and
the corresponding software
for Elastifile, you can
deploy this cluster easily.
And also then mount your
client from that region.
So if I want to do
something like us-central1,
and select the particular
zone, I can do that.
Or select Regional
and Elastifile
managed service
will do it for you.
You have the ability
to then select
the service class to expect
high performance, general use,
or something else.
And then you can see underneath
here, Estimated Total.
This is really
great, because you
can see [INAUDIBLE] the
cost [? association ?]
is going to be.
This is an estimate.
But you know at the
end of the month what'd
you'd be expecting
to use subjected
to that particular
service class.
And then you can select
Allocated Capacity.
All this is dynamic,
sliders will change.
It's a really easy way to see
what this cost is going to be.
From here you can do
Authorized Networks.
This is where you set up
your VPC peering network,
either local or shared.
I've got a couple before
that I can select,
but if you haven't done it, from
the UI, prompts will show up.
You copy it.
You throw in your terminal.
It's up and running in no time.
And you don't have to
do anything outside
of the console.
There's a couple
advanced options
we can show you as well.
So if you're restricting
client access
or opening up client
access, you have the ability
to create read-write
rules or delete
read-write rules that exist.
And then enable snapshots
straight from the UI.
So all one page, all easily.
I'm going to hit Cancel just to
give you a quick view of what
it looks like on the main page.
And then you have
the ability, kind
of similar to what we
were talking about before,
but logging in to Stackdriver
to get advanced analytics
and metrics.
So if you want to
have logs data,
I can select any one of
my existing instances,
and it'll redirect me within the
console to see what's going on.
But if I want to log
out of Stackdriver
instead of alerting
or reporting,
we have that functionality too.
Super-quick demo.
Come talk to us
afterwards and I'll
give you a more robust one.
But I want to pass the
mic back over to Allon so
that he can show you what
this looks like to scale out
Elastifile Cloud File Service.
ALLON COHEN: Thank you, Devin.
So we did want to show you
a bit of this in action,
so if we can switch back
to the other computer.
What we're going to
show you is essentially
a demo of an HPC workload.
We'll do this in three arenas.
On the top right, you see
the performance coming
from the Elastifile system.
On the bottom right,
you see the Google
console showing you the
VMs that we're spinning up.
And on the left, you
actually see orchestration.
We are fully accessible via API.
And in this case, we're using
Slurm to automate the bring up
of 1,000 VMs.
These are preemptible VMs,
which is another great reason
to use a file service.
You can save a lot by
using the preemptible VMs.
If someone falls, no issue.
You have persistent
storage as a service.
You spin up another VM
through the orchestration,
and that VM will
access the data.
We have just spun up
1,000 of these VMs
through orchestration.
And what I want you
to follow is a bit
of the throughput that we are
achieving and the connections.
We're actually
using two NFS mounts
for each one of those VMs.
So you can see the count
of connections rising up.
Right now at 1,300, growing
up to those 2,000 connections
for those 2,000 VMs.
And the throughput
we're running now
is upward of 2.4
gigabytes per second.
This is not the limit,
but in terms of cost,
even though we're
using preemptible VMs,
we didn't want to go
much beyond 1,000.
You see now a tail
there of workloads,
and that's actually the
orchestration system
bringing up additional VMs
which were preempted earlier.
So if you needed to complete
the project, no problem.
Through the automations, even
though Google infrastructure
took one of your VMs, they're
simply spun back up and used.
As Devin said, come ask us
afterwards any questions.
And we also have a
booth here, which
we can show you for the demos.
Thank you.
Back to you, Tad.
[APPLAUSE]
TAD HUNT: Cool.
Thank you, Allon and Devin.
That was a really exciting demo.
Anyone ever see in
anyone's cloud scaling
up to that many gigabytes
per second of throughput
that quickly?
That was pretty awesome.
So next up, we're going to
have Niraj from NetApp give us
a talk about Cloud Volumes,
their new Cloud Volumes
Service from NetApp.
So please join me
in welcoming Niraj.
[APPLAUSE]
NIRAJ VERMA: Thank you
all for being here.
TAD HUNT: Come on this side.
NIRAJ VERMA: [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you, Tad.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Niraj Verma, technical
marketing engineer here
at NetApp.
I recently joined our Cloud
Data Services business unit.
I focus solely on Cloud
Volumes Service for GCP.
And I'm very
interested in listening
to what you have to say on what
you see today, the demo as well
as the product.
I work very closely with
the product manager.
I'd love to bring back
some feedback or questions
that you may have.
Clicker.
With that, just to
frame the conversation,
we'll spend just maybe five
minutes on this one slide.
And then I'll go into
a basic demo of the UI.
And then after
that, I'll show you
another demo of an
application use case
where we go through some of
the features of the product.
So we'll first
define the service.
What is NetApp Cloud
Volumes Service?
The simplest way
to think of it is
that it is an NFS or an SMB
endpoint in Google Cloud.
And as far as the features
and some of the benefits
that you get for your
applications, your system
design, and your users, first
we have the standard file
interfaces that you can deploy.
You have your NFS for
your Unix applications
and SMB for your
Windows applications.
And one thing to
point out here is
that NetApp has been
a pioneer and a leader
in the shared file space
for over two decades now.
And we bring that experience,
and more importantly,
the stability of our
technology to Google Cloud.
Next-- sorry, I
should've mentioned
going from top left down.
Second, we have the fully
managed service tenant
where we don't want you to be
in the business of standing up
this infrastructure, underlying
infrastructure, even one time.
So right when you deploy your
application from the get-go,
you have this available
for you to quickly spin up
an amount on your
application without having
to then even worry about the
lifecycle of that application
when it comes to
patching or scaling
the storage that it's using.
Multiple performance levels--
the service comes in three
flavors--
standard, premium, and extreme.
Each of these three flavors
have a performance metric
associated with it.
And I'll show you more
of that in the demo.
But think of it as a
two-dimensional surface--
capacity and performance.
And you get it in three
different flavors--
standard, premium, and extreme.
The fourth thing
on the bottom left,
rich data management, this, for
us, is a key differentiator.
We not only allow you
to quickly spin up
endpoints for your
application, but we also
think about the lifecycle
of that endpoint
when it comes to
protecting your data,
as well as creating rapid copies
for your application lifecycle,
going from dev to test staging
on your pathway to production.
Moving to the top right,
native service experience.
Now, experience was a
key design goal for us
when we started working
on this service.
And you'll see in the
demo next, in the basic UI
demo, what I mean by that.
You don't have to go outside
the Google legal system
in your application
storage journey.
When it comes to support,
again, as I mentioned,
experience was not just from
a look and feel standpoint.
We also wanted to think about
your journey as an engineer,
as an architect, as a
DevOps engineer when
it comes to support.
We know that things
are going to break
and you're going
to need some help.
So what we've done
here is that we
allow you to talk to your same
Google ecosystem for your level
one support.
And NetApp will work with you
on the backend for L2 and L3
escalation cases as needed.
And billing is also integrated.
We don't want you to
manage a second contract
or second piece of paper.
You get the same bill
that you get from Google,
with the line item for NetApp
based on the performance
service level that you choose.
And being a true
cloud service, we also
allow you to pay for what
you use on an hourly basis
as you go.
With that, I'll move over to
my laptop for a quick UI demo.
All right, so as
you can see here,
I'm currently logging
into the Google console.
And I'm currently in
the API library page.
And I can simply
type NetApp here.
And it brings up the NetApp
Cloud Volumes Service API.
Since I already have it enabled,
I can then click on Manage.
And this brings me into the
dashboard for Cloud Volumes
Service.
Listed here are some volumes
that I created in the ue-east4
region--
way too many of them.
You can see quickly the name,
all the key detail that you
need, just to get a quick
snapshot of your state,
the region, lifecycle if
it's available and mounted,
service level, the
mount pad capacity,
and the protocol
that you're using.
On the left, you see this
tab right here, the Volume,
and then you also have a
Snapshot tab, which I'll
talk about in a second here.
And then you have the
AD Connections tab
for your SMB volume creation.
So I'm going to go
and click Create.
And here, you can see that I
have two options, NFS and SMB.
I'm going to give it a
name here real quick.
Pay attention to
how much time it
takes for me to go from
here to the volume creation.
And I'll tell you why.
So once I give it a name, I have
the path automatically chosen
for me.
You can change it, but
make sure if you change it,
it's unique across
the entire project.
Speaking of service
level, here they
are-- three service levels
with the performance that you
can expect from each of them.
If you stop by the
NetApp booth, I
can demonstrate the performance
aspect of these three
live over there.
But for now, I'm going to
choose us-east4 region.
This tab right
here, Snapshot, now,
this allows you to
create an on-demand--
create a volume,
just like we are,
from a snapshot
that you previously
created of another volume
from that tab on the top left.
We're not doing that in this
case, so I'll skip that.
We're creating a new
volume, so I'll give it
a minimum size of 1 terabyte.
And then you have your
standard NFS export policy
permissioning.
I'm going to add a
rule to open all.
I'm very generous
with my security.
So I open it to all clients.
And then I can choose
Read and Write.
And with that done, last
thing I'll mention here
before I click Save
is I can now also take
snapshots in an automated
fashion, where I can then
set my schedule-- hourly, daily,
weekly, minutes-- and also
my retention.
I'm not doing that in this case.
I'll click Save.
As I mentioned, pay attention.
I clicked Save, and it
takes me a couple seconds.
So we actually-- you
didn't hear this from me--
we have a contest
going on in our booth.
If you do this and
you do it the fastest,
then you'll get a
Bose wireless headset.
You didn't hear
this from me, again.
Right now, I think the
clock is about 25 seconds.
And I think you can
easily beat that.
This is the basic demo.
I'm not going to mount
this volume to an instance,
but I'll show you, if you wanted
to do that, you can quickly
click on this icon right here.
And you can check out
your mount instructions.
Simply copy and paste
that in your SSH session
and you'll be able to do that.
Now, with this basic demo
coming to a conclusion,
I'm going to switch over
to an application demo.
I've kept this
application demo simple.
What I have here is a
Google Cloud Instance,
compute instance, which I
call confluence-next-demo.
And in the next screen, I have
a cloud volume from that app,
also called
confluence-next-data.
And what I'm doing is I'm
installing confluence.
This is an application example
of an enterprise content
management system where you're
sharing and collaborating
files.
So I install that app
on that Google instance,
and then I switch the
directory for data
to that cloud volume
I just created.
The app is installed.
Now what I'll do is I'll fire
it up, create a new workspace,
call it DevOps, and then I'll
add some data, some couple
of web pages and
some pictures, just
to show you a production state.
You have some data running
on your application.
Once this is done, what I'm
going to try to depict here
is that now you have data
and application running
on Cloud Volumes in Google,
and you're, let's say,
in production, right?
And maybe you have
a business need.
You want to make some changes
to your steady state and you
want to maybe do an
upgrade or add some--
or maybe move this copy
of your entire application
to another environment,
let's say, PT--
or something.
So what you can then do is you
can take an on-demand snapshot
that I showed you in
the UI demo earlier.
You do that by clicking on
that top left Snapshot icon,
or you can edit the volume.
Once you take the
snapshot, the nice thing
is that then you can
clone the snapshot
and create a new volume
from that snapshot.
This volume that's
been created is now
going to be also
resized in the process.
So you can change it from
1 terabyte to 2 terabytes.
Now you mount it back to
your confluence instance.
And you'll notice
that I'll change
the directory for the
data, and I'll still
have all of my web
pages and the data
that I created in
the previous step.
Got a bit ahead of myself.
There it is.
So the new data volume was
mounted, and I have my data.
At the same time, I'm also
migrating my application
from version 6.1 to the
latest version of this app.
And I can do that
now because I'm
confident that if
anything goes wrong,
I can go back to that point
in time copy of the snapshot
that I created.
That's the demo.
Thank you.
Can I switch back
to the PowerPoint?
Next slide.
I should do that.
OK, so just to--
on a closing note, the service
is currently in paid alpha.
So you have to be whitelisted
in order to access the service.
But that's changing next month
when we go to beta release.
A couple of new features that
are coming out with beta--
we'll be exposing our API.
So now you can take that API and
programmatically access Cloud
Volumes with other
Google technologies,
and provision that from your
Google Cloud command line
tools.
And the other cool feature
that's coming out in beta
is that we'll be automating the
entire process of whitelisting
and onboarding, so you can
now, in a self-service fashion,
access to services open to
all, basically, next month.
From a regional
standpoint, currently we
are available in central-1
and us-east4 regions.
But we'll be adding
us-west1, which is LA,
and eu-west2, which I
believe is Frankfurt,
in the summer time frame.
And then following that
would be London and Sydney.
I think I'll stop
with that, Tad.
So thank you all for listening.
And back to you.
TAD HUNT: Great.
Awesome demo.
Thanks, Niraj.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
So that was a great demo of some
key enterprise collaboration
workflow on GCP, and of course,
the UI for the Cloud Volumes
Service.
So this is at the
wrap-up section,
so I'm just going to
summarize what we covered.
We covered Cloud
Filestore's ability
to do some general
purpose NAS and drill down
into the dev test area.
We looked at Elastifile's
GKE and preemptable VM story
for large scale.
And we looked at NetApps
Enterprise Content Management.
So I think the really
cool thing here
is you see three different
managed services all built
on GCP.
And what we talked about at
our keynote this morning,
the open source
services platform,
and bringing open source in.
We're actually doing
the same thing.
And we've really prototyped
that these industry partners
as well.
So of course, there's
a lot of more workloads
that all of our partners
in Filestore can do.
So please check out
these folks' websites,
some of the other
sessions we talked about,
and everything else out there.
The key takeaway here is, if you
walk away with only one thing,
is Google Cloud is actually
very ready for your enterprise
workloads.
Bring them on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]